thank you for tuning in as we go over
the identification of protein biomarkers
in the era of precision medicine
oncology
my name is hilal arnouk i am a
pathologist and a cancer researcher
our objective today is to highlight the
role of proteomics
in precision medicine oncology and go
over one approach
using clinical proteomics as a tool to
identify novel biomarkers
as you are fully aware cancer is a
leading cause for morbidity and
mortality
in developed nations like the united
states
it is estimated that
one in two men and one in three women
will experience cancer in their lifetime
it should be mentioned that cancer
mortality is slowly declining over the
last few decades
at a rate of about 20 percent over the
last two decades
and that is due in large part to
early detection of cancers
specifically before they metastasize
and become incurable
in fact
early detection
and prevention
have been the best weapons we have
against cancer
since this country declared war on
cancer with the signing of the national
cancer act in 1971.
traditionally pathologists
classified cancers based on their
appearance under the microscope or what
we call morphology
however with the advancements of the
fields of genomics and proteomics
specifically after the completion of the
human genome sequence
we are able now to
utilize these tools
to look for molecular signatures
for every cancer
specifically looking at the normal
processes and pathways in a cell
that become hijacked by
the malignant cell
for
transformation and later on the steps of
tumor progression
so in proteomics we hope to
map or profile the protein landscape of
a biological sample
it could be a tissue sample or it could
be a
serum sample for example
in either case
we can do
expression analysis looking for proteins
that are upregulated down regulated or
missing or we can also look for their
function
or what we call functional proteomics
now why do we look for
protein biomarkers in specific
we like proteins because they are the
functional unit in the cell
moreover they tend to be more diverse
and complex
than their cousins
in the dna or rna
specifically they tend to preserve
or retain all the upstream
[Music]
genetic information
like mutations in the dna
they can also tell us about
gene expression and epigenetic
regulation of gene expression
they could also reflect processes
upstream
such as alternative splicing or
post-translational modifications
so the example we are going over today
has to do with cervical cancer
cervical cancer is
one of the most common cancers in women
worldwide i think right now it ranks as
number four
it affects about half a million women
every year
and for about half of these patients it
turned out to be fatal
as many of you know this is a type of
cancer that starts with a viral
infection specifically
with the high risk human papilloma
viruses
and over the course of a decade or so
the lesions can progress from
premalignant
into invasive carcinoma and later on
into metastatic
carcinoma
so
because of all of that
cervical cancer is an ideal
disease for screening tools as i will
show you a little later
so about 99
of all cervical cancer cases can be
linked directly to infections with high
risk hpv
and the link between a viral infection
and the cancer is that
hpv has
viral proteins specifically
e6 and e7
that bind to
and disable or degrade two tumor
suppressor genes p53 and the
retinoblastoma tumor suppressor gene
and by doing this
disables the mechanisms that are in
charge of dna damage surveillance
and
the brakes on the cell cycle in this
case
so the effects of
the virus on the tumor suppressor genes
will manifest as increased proliferation
and increase genetic instability in
these cells
with increased genetic instability
the epithelial cells in the cervix
accumulate more and more mutations
and it is a stepwise progression that
can manifest at the histopathology level
in these lesions shown here
so
the picture to your left is showing us
the
normal cervical squamous epithelium
the three
slides after that are presenting what we
call pre-cancerous or
pre-malignant lesions
they are also abbreviated as sin for
cervical
intra-epithelial neoplasm
and the reason they are numbered one two
three
they are representing increasing level
of atp
at the cell level
and at the architectural level of the
tissues
pathologists call this
these atypical features dysplasia
so while sin one will display mild
dysplasia sin 2 has moderate dysplasia
and sin 3
has
severe dysplasia
and in sin 3 the dysplasia involves all
the layers
and in fact it overlaps with another
designation that we call carcinoma in
situ
so at this level there is high potential
of progressing into invasive carcinoma
the only reason we don't call it
invasive at this point is that the
malignant cells have not broken through
the basement membrane
yet
now the last picture here to the right
is showing us an invasive carcinoma at
this level it's micro invasion
as we see a few cancer cells breaking
through the basement membrane
now the outcome from these premalignant
lesions could be very different so while
most
or the majority of sin one lesions
tend to regress in time
and only small percentage of them will
progress to send to and send through and
be beyond
however once we reach sim 3 there is a
real possibility of progression into
cancer and it is estimated to be about
10 to 20 percent
so because of this difference in
potential between sin one on one side
and sin two and three on the other side
the classification was
simplified further
by calling sin one lesion low-grade
squamous intra-epithelial lesion or
l-cell
and combining sin 2 and 3 into
high-grade lesions or itself
and
this coordinates with also
two-tier
clinical decision so while the
course of action for the low-grade
lesions is just to monitor them
the high-grade lesions require surgical
removal
in the united states approximately 13
000 cases of the invasive
carcinoma is diagnosed every year
now compare that to about one million of
the pre-cancerous lesions
and the reason behind this is the
successful application of a screening
tool called the pap test named after a
pathologist
dr papa nicola
the application for the pap test for
the last few decades has reduced
mortality from cervical cancer by some
estimates by about fourfold
and in this test the pathologist or
psychologist is looking for
a few surface cells that are shed by the
cervix of the uterus
and this is how they look like so
panel a is showing us the normal
superficial squamous epithelial cells of
the cervix
as we move on to panel b then c and d we
have all the inter-epithelial
pre-malignant lesions from sin one to
sin three
and notice
the increasing level of atypia
combined with increased nucleus to
cytoplasm ratio
reflecting perhaps the loss of
differentiation as we go through the
progression
of the pre-malignant lesions
although the pap test has been
successful as a screening tool it has
its own shortcomings
for once in
the 50 million women that undergo the
screening every year about 2 to 3
million of them
will be referred for further evaluation
or what we call ascus atypical squamous
cells of undetermined significance
moreover the pap test suffers from
inter-observer variability so it is a
subjective test
which will lead to poor sensitivity and
specificity
and just as a reminder so when we are
talking about a cancer test sensitivity
we refer to
the fact that a test that is 100 percent
sensitive will be able to diagnose all
patients with cancer
as such
while a cancer test that has poorer
sensitivity
will allow some patients to go
undetected and that's what we call false
negative
and obviously these patients now have
missed opportunities to diagnose their
cancer and treat it so they also live
with the false sense of security
while if a cancer test is not a hundred
percent
specific
it will allow
people who are
free to be diagnosed as having the
disease or what we call false positive
and that is bad in a different way that
will lead to
diagnosis of cancer in patients who do
not have the cancer
and will be followed up
probably by unnecessary
costly and invasive procedures
not to mention the emotional toll on the
patient
so then the goal of this study is to
identify
molecular markers specifically protein
markers that will help us
identify the different
stages of cervical cancer progression
so we started by collecting
10 samples from patients who have the
high grade
pre-malignant lesions and we also
collected
10 normal samples from the same patients
separately we obtained
10 biopsies from patients who have the
full-blown invasive squamous cell
carcinoma
and the experimental design of this
project was to
[Music]
take the tissue biopsies
apply laser capture micro dissection to
enrich for the phenotype of interest
then extract
the proteome from all these samples
separate all the proteins in it
into two-dimensional gel electrophoresis
combined with fluorescent probes
that will allow differential analysis
that is computer assisted and combined
with statistical methods
that will generate a list of potential
biomarkers that subsequently will be
identified using mass spectrometry and
bioinformatics
so i will walk you through all these
steps
specifically the
logic behind the experimental design
so
we all know that tumors are complex
in addition to having
malignant cells they also within the
tumor tissue you will find mesenchymal
cells like fibroblasts
endothelial cells of the blood vessels
inflammatory and immune cells
so then
we needed a way to be able to isolate
cancer cells from
the rest of
the cell types
and for that we used a technique called
laser capture micro dissection
which will allow us in real time to look
at tissue samples
and
isolate
the cancer cells by
lifting them onto a plastic cap
so here in this slide i'm showing you
real samples that we
applied laser capture micro dissection
to
so in the top panel we are looking at
the normal epithelium of the cervix
and in the first picture you see the
full tissue and in the last one you see
the one lifted onto
the cap
and similarly the bottom panel is
showing us
cancer sample
so if we focus on what we isolated on
the plastic cap we can see that we
enriched for the phenotype of interest
meaning in this case we isolated the
epithelial tissues whether they are
normal or cancerous
and we left behind
the connective tissue or straw
now if we take the tissue that was
collected on the plastic cap
and
lyse these cells to extract all the
proteins in them
we'll be able then to separate all the
thousands of proteins coming from each
cell type onto
two-dimensional gel electrophoresis
which utilizes separation by charge in
the first dimension
combined with separation by size in the
second dimension
moreover
we can utilize fluorescent probes in
what's called differential in-gel
electrophoresis or dyes
and in this case the two com compared
samples will be labeled separately with
two different fluorescent
probes
being combined together and separated on
the same gel
for instance if we are comparing
normal cervical epithelium to invasive
carcinoma
we will label each protein sample with a
different
fluorescent side eye
together separate them on the dye gel
and then we'll be able to scan for each
one of the fluorescent probes separately
then
use computer assisted analysis to gain
information about the relative abundance
of each
protein spot
in the two compared samples
so here i will walk you through the
story of one of these spots on the die
shell
this spot happened to have number 667
and what we notice about it that it
tends to have a very consistent trend
so while in the normal
epithelium it has a considerable level
of expression
that level of expression is down
regulated significantly in the
pre-malignant lesions
by about five volts
it is down regulated further as we go
into the invasive carcinoma
and the difference between the normal
tissues and the carcinoma samples was
about ten fold
and this trend was consistent amongst
all the 10 collected biopsies for each
group
so the mission then is to identify the
protein
that is in this spot
so for that first we precisely excise
the spot of interest using a robotic arm
then digest the protein inside the gel
plug using trypsin
that will generate tryptic peptides
that can be
measured using mass spectrometry
the resulting pattern is known as
peptide mass fingerprint
and using bioinformatics tools will be
able to compare or match the peptide
mass fingerprint resulting from this
protein spot
to a theoretical peptide mass
fingerprint in the database
that is
theoretically based on the genome
database
and by doing this we identify the
protein in the spot
so here is the peptide mass fingerprint
resulting from
spot number six six seven
when
used in a
protein database search
it gave a clear match on a protein named
cornell
and a similarity score was high this is
the number 220 here according to the
algorithm used in the match
scores over 64 in this case will be
significant match
the e value refers to the probability
that there is a chance there is another
protein match that has similar or
greater
similarity score
than cornell
but as you can see this number is very
very small
so at this point
this gives us confidence that there was
only one protein in the spot
and that is cornea
so at that point not much was known
about corneline except that it is a
biomarker for late epidermal
differentiation in the
stratified squamous epithelium of the
epidermis
and there was at least one study showing
decrease or loss of expression for
cornulin in esophageal cancer
so at this point we want to take a
protein marker that is identified by de
novo discovery and
transform it to where it can be used in
a routine
clinical pathology lab
and these slabs traditionally have
immunohistochemistry ability
so with the specific antibody again
against corneline we can go back and
stain
the biopsies
for corneline and the trend we observed
with the 2d gel was preserved in
immunohistochemistry
so as you can see going from left to
right the normal epithelium of the
cervix has
abundance of corneline mostly in the
upper layers of the epithelium
and there is down
regulation in the pre-malignant lesions
the ed cell
and almost
loss of expression in the invasive
carcinoma
now if we were to extend this discovery
and find out if corneline can also be
used as a prognostic marker
we went back and acquired tissue
microarray
that have
cervical cancer and pre-malignant
lesions in it and all its variation
for instance
an important histopathological parameter
is known as histopathological grade
and as we go from grade 1 to grade 3
there is loss of differentiation
which normally is associated with
increase in the aggressiveness of that
cancer
now when we stained all these tissue
microarrays for corneline we observed
that corneline tends to be
more
downregulated in the high grades of two
and three
thus that makes it a prognostic marker
in addition to being a diagnostic marker
in addition to corneal n we also
identified 22
potential markers from the 2d gel
experiment
and we envisioned that creating a panel
of the most promising markers
can
potentially augment the predictive power
of the histopathological examination
of cervical cancer tissues but also the
pre-malignant and normal tissues
interestingly enough when we did
a basic science experiment taking
keratinocytes that were immortalized by
the human papilloma virus
a lot of these
markers also
hold true
meaning they are also upregulated or
down regulated accordingly
in the immortalized cells
here i have shown you a proteomics
approach to identify novel biomarkers
for cancer
however
proteomics can be complemented nicely by
other omix techniques with the goal of
stratifying patients that
seemingly have the same disease or the
same cancer
into subgroups
we call this molecular profiling and it
could result in prognostic markers like
i showed you for cornelium for example
it could uncover
predictive markers for the sensitivity
to a certain cancer treatment or even
resistance to a treatment
they might also predict adverse events
in certain patients
so by stratifying the patients into
subgroups we can now tailor
specific
targeted therapy for each group of
patients thus maximizing
the cure rate and survival
all this is part of the emerging field
of precision medicine oncology
thank you for tuning in and if you have
any question please forward them my way